I love Japanese games as you might be
able to guess this is a Japanese game
the name translates to this what you
should right area maze and I will let
you decide later on why you think it's
cold that okay now the question what
what I love about these puzzles is that
you I always don't need to explain what
to do with these right because it simply
says look there are some numbers and
then there's one number you don't know
can you find it that's all there is to
us right no words I love that okay so
here's the important part right this is
what I'm good at you do what we got so
I'm gonna get you to do one more thing
above just finding these numbers I want
you and this is actually the most
important bit so you leave your books
with you I want you to not just find out
what these numbers are but also tell me
how you got them so I'm gonna model that
for you I don't expect you know how to
do that right away so let me show you
let's do this press 1 so they do get a
bit harder by the way and as you can see
if you've turned over the page if you're
really really really brave you can have
a go at this one because some of you'll
be like oh this is easy okay and you'll
see what I mean have a look at this all
the shapes are rectangles okay so I want
to find out what this gray shape is so
because there are rectangles I know see
how there's a four up there see how
that's four at the top that means that
this is four down to bottom do you see
that maybe you want to add that into
your diagram that's four okay alright
well if that's four then that tells me
the width of the big rectangle do you
see that what's the wreath of the big
rectangle it's seven right it's it's the
song but look I also know that the area
of that rectangle is 42 square
centimeters so I can use that to find
out the height what's the height it's
six very good but if that Sikhs
and this length over here is 10 then
this guy over here is 4 so our answer is
16 now remember I said to you I what did
you do these two things I want you to
find those numbers but I also what
should tell me how so in your book after
you just do do what I just did okay
here's what you might write in your book
here's an example ok let's get rid of
all of this again you might write
something like this number one your so
your first step okay step one maybe you
want to give these names so I'm going to
call this rectangle a and rectangle B
the width of rectangle a is 4 on the top
so then what did I conclude from that
how did I use that fact so it's what
remember I went across to the other side
so I'm going to say it's 4 on the bottom
do you agree with that do you remember I
went through that's my logic okay that's
that's that's what I've done there okay
that was my first step and then my
second step was does anyone remember
when I did second yeah yeah very good I
combined these two to say so the width
of B must be 6 sorry
7 I've got ahead of myself right at 7 so
how did I use that what was my next step
yeah that's right the area of B is 42 so
the height whoops
is asthma I just said 42 divided by 7
which is 6 what was there there are only
two more steps right do you remember
what the last two sets were how did I
use that 6 look at the left-hand side
look at the left remember I had
something to do with this guy ah I said
so the what length of my working out
what would you call this thing what name
would you give it it's the height of a
so the height of a is 10 take away 6
which as you said was 4 and then you can
do the last step from there okay Maria
well okay so that was my first one I'm
telling you this so that when you have a
go at this one you know what I'm
expecting of you try and find the number
and then tell me how you found it but
how is the most important bit okay